Screen Rant reports that the Sandman has
weighed in on whether or not he would
ever join a movie franchise like Marvel
Adam said quote I've never thought about
it maybe because no one has ever asked
me and he added that he loves those
movies but it is at this point in his
career it probably won't happen I think
that
affirmations are like a thought that
becomes a seed that gets planted in the
universe and then blooms so I have a
feeling you know now that he said this
you know people at like the comic book
you know factories are like what about
Sandler yeah he'd be great I mean he's
hilarious he's like a great actor what
if he played like a villain you know
what I mean like a hilarious Opera man
SNL kind of a villain in a Marvel movie
I do love the idea of seeing Adam as a
villain just in general because it's
like he's so safe and if you took that
safety away and he's such a good actor
he can do no wrong